[Musique]
ça ne t'a pas touché que nous soyons là
dans lequel il y a plus de 5 morts et moi rien
en plus je fais un quart de 8h
la critique ne dit pas
le jaune sur une note rouge est une note
qui parle d'une maladie sociale qui
nous vivons dans ce pays qui vont au
fille et violence aussi impunité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils disent qu'il y a eu une fusillade et
on regarde s'il y avait du monde
froid 12 degrés avec deux blessés un Z1
un tué par Paz Medical Fort
arme à feu
nous allons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et un compagnon d'un compagnon
on passe de la moto
[Musique]
nous sommes en coordination avec des équipes de
urgences médicales
policiers en tout nous avons découvert quelque chose
c'est déjà arrivé
au revoir je lui tire dessus
et l'homme est resté là et puis les choses n'ont pas marché
ils ont tiré ça vient ils ne couvrent pas un
van ils ne l'ont pas identifié et pour
ce qu'il voit il n'y a pas de famille et il vit mais
qu'ils sachent qui il est
qui a environ 25 ans
et qu'il a une balle dans le dos
[Musique]
ils te traitent
entraver le travail même lorsque
respectez votre zone protégée par eux
J'essaie toujours d'entraver
c'est notre travail
[Musique]
Catalogue
Philippe
n'enlevons pas car c'est une propriété privée
J'aime la partie que nous sommes
vivant
[Musique]
nous vivons dans cette ville
on partage ça
notion d'insécurité
[Musique]
et violences
psychologique très fort
[Musique]
terrible nous pleurons fille
dormi pendant la journée et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce que la presse mexicaine a dit est presque
meurt d'amour en romantisant tout
instant violence basée sur le genre
nous vivons la femme
manifester devant la presse
ce que nous recevons en retour, eh bien
c'est une série de coups que tu n'embrasseras pas
[Applaudissements]
parler d'une société qui parle de
torture envers les femmes avec un
naturalité brutale nous juste quoi
nous voulions qu'il génère une règle qui
la conscience sociale est générée parmi
journalistes et qu'ils ont compris qu'un
la note rouge est une note qui parle d'un
sinistre qui parle d'un fait
criminel
[Musique]
tu as entendu pourquoi tu seras
vous avez couru
[Musique]
J'ai aimé
elle aussi
[Musique]
on le déballe
mais plutôt le rythme de vie en ville
du Mexique est si chaotique qu'un certain nombre
Il paraît que ça fait partie de la vie
tous les jours et doit continuer sa vie
d'une manière très particulière avec ce
genre de situation
Hey
Je suis d'accord avec les démonstrations
que les raisons sont super légitimes
pour qui tu fais et cent quoi
important, en tant que journaliste, je pense que
je vais
me questionne beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'aujourd'hui que demain que vous le prochain
semaine je vais continuer à faire un travail
et je vais voir des choses terribles mais aussi
Je veux continuer à le faire parce que je pense
c'est important
je veux
pouvoir avoir plus de temps pour
être proche de ma famille parce que quoi
Je vois cette mort énervée alors je
je veux quand
Je reconnais que les premiers mois
étaient très compliqués pour moi car
fin sont les gens qui avaient un
famille décédée dans des situations très
triste et tu fais ta vie mais tu dis qu'il y a dedans
le matin un homme est mort et le pauvre
et donc
Je pense qu'il a un peu souffert de la façon dont
avoir autant de pensées comme celle-ci
[Musique]
la note rouge est que nous ne savons pas quand
nous allons mourir
[Musique]
et ça m'a donné beaucoup à apprécier aussi
la vie
[Musique]